la semaine dernière l'entourage d'Al
Pacino âgé de 83 ans créait la surprise
en annonçant qu'il allait devenir père
pour la quatrième fois avec sa nouvelle
compagne de seulement 29 ans un écartage
important et un bébé en route qui a valu
à la légende du 7e art de nombreuses
critiques quelque chose de complètement
égoïsteindir et alors que l'acteur
oscarisé se croyait devenu stérile et ne
souhaitait pas avoir d'autres enfants il
a décidé de faire une démarche étonnante
un test que s'accompagnerait accepté et
qui se serait révélé positif selon la
presse people américaine et vous
avez-vous une confiance aveugle en votre
partenaire
que je viens de recevoir le test
[Musique]
il est positif donc c'est bien Al Pacino
avoir un gros doute comme ça et lui
demander un test mais non mais c'est pas
par rapport à elle en fait il explique
que comme il souffrait d'un problème de
santé dont il pensait qu'il l'avait
rendu stéril il a voulu savoir voilà
ça veut dire qu'il a un doute
ça c'est le prétexte la vérité
c'est que ces enfants ses enfants ne
veulent pas de cette nouvelle paternité
et il a tenté de vouloir les rassurer et
comme il a une liaison avec nous qui est
une liaison parfois intermittente il
s'est dit je vais essayer s'il y a une
brèche de montrer que ce n'est pas moi
le père mais je trouve ça scandaleux et
disgracieux avec un manque de confiance
totale Cyril est-ce qu'on peut dire que
ce qui est scandaleux c'est qu'elle est
29 ans
ça peut être légal et on peut être
contre aussi
contre parce qu'en fait il a 83 ans elle
a 29 ans et à mon avis si elle lui fait
un gosse c'est pas pour ses beaux yeux
il va être heureux comme tout ouais elle
elle est très heureuse d'être son enfant
sa première année après il va décéder
normalement
il est pas caramélisé éternel il est
éternels très bien leurs enfants sont
très heureux c'est un choix mais là les
michtonner un gars juste avant qui
meurent alors
c'est bon là deux minutes là s'il te
plaît attention
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
vous défendre ça c'est incroyable
s'il était livreur de pizza
tu dis toujours
exige et exagéré
il y a eu un mec
là il faut un test de paternité de jour
après par contre
si c'était pas le Patino Al Pacino tal
Pacino parce que c'est un Pacino
s'il te plaît
la dernière fois quand on aime quelqu'un
on l'aime pour tout ce qu'il représente
bien sûr la nana qui est avec toi elle
t'aime parce que tu es aussi le mec qui
passe à la télé parce que
tu crois vraiment tu crois vraiment que
si c'était pas la télé tu pêcherais des
meufs non
mais pareil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas pareil
toi qui est le policier du couple
Guillaume une relation c'est toujours
intéressé c'est deux personnes qui sont
ensemble pour des raisons qui les
regarde là les deux ils sont ensemble
pour des raisons et les deux là ça leur
convient donc ça ne te regarde pas
dessus parce qu'elle est vraiment
choquée
elle est même elle est délice elle est
délice qui
quand tu mets le petit drapeau
mais quand je vois 50 temps d'écart donc
c'est 53 € 53 ans 53 ans déjà
permettez-moi de donner mon avis et moi
je trouve que selon moi et je respecte
les gens qui n'ont pas le même avec moi
selon moi 53 ans d'écart je me pose
quelques questions et au-delà de ça
avoir un enfant à 82 ans
accepté de le voir que les trois
premières années de sa vie
pour faire toutes les activités avec son
enfant
les gens vivent de plus en plus les gens
vivent de plus en plus longtemps et ils
sont en meilleure santé moi j'ai plein
plein d'amis qui ont eu des enfants à 70
ans à 70 ans ils sont parents ils sont
en plein de choses avec leurs enfants
avec leurs enfants
une vingtaine un petit peu plus
précisément 35 quoi
je suis en train de faire des calculs
j'espère que tu nous as pas fait une
connerie avec la mère de ma fille
[Rires]
c'est bon ça passe
monsieur
[Applaudissements]
véhicule pour y aller merci c'est parti
merci merci que la visibilité la
notoriété et tout ça ça permet
de draguer d'avoir des enfants mieux que
dans sa catégorie normalement officielle
de 80 piges il est pas censé avoir envie
d'une meuf de 20 ans je suis désolé
[Musique]
j'ai vu des potes c'est pas des potes je
connaissais des mecs de 80 ans leurs
zizi n'a pas pris une rime comment tu
sais ce que tu vois leur zizi comment ça
se fait que tu vois leur zizi déjà parce
que généralement par curiosité
[Rires]
ça veut dire parce que c'est mon exposé
donc peut-être il faut qu'on se pose la
question
en fait
le plus de vieux zizi elle est là merci
non mais c'est jalouses ton vieux zizi
on vieux pané j'y pense en fait j'ai vu
de 55 à 70 à peu près il avait pas pris
une ride et je l'ai je l'ai quasiment
jamais connu au repos en fait j'ai posé
la question
c'est une michto regarde par exemple
parce que toi c'est pas tes goûts mais
imagine Jean-Pierre Jean d'Ormesson mais
c'est des c'est des mecs sublimes à plus
franchement elle est en train tu Gênes
tout le monde
arrête
non mais j'aime beaucoup
arrête arrête je suis arrête arrête
arrête arrête
de l'âge de Al Pacino à peu près avec un
garçon très jeune alors tout aussi
ridicule ah mais vraiment sincèrement
mais par exemple on a un président qui
est
un président qui a une grosse différence
d'âge avec sa femme et le Président je
peux pas me le voir en peinture
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]